I have 80 apartments.
I have quite several buildings close to 200 tenants.
You built up quite an empire.
Yes, I built these with my own hands.
And recognizing that so many of his tenants...
...had been hit financially because of the coronavirus,...
...he decided to waive the rent for the month of April.
Mario, what made you decide to waive the rent for all your 200 tenants?
Because I had a lot of my tenants losing their jobs.
I wanted them to have some peace of mind, not to worry about where their next dollar was.
As a human, I felt a lot more comfortable...
...making sure that they had food on their table, with several of them didn't...
...and I felt very honored to tell them that.
But presumably, you're taking a hard hit on this financially.
How much are you losing?
We don't want to really bring that issue up.
That's irrelevant to the value of human life,...
...and which I value people's lives.
I left the big sign right here on the door.
I told, very important, all the tenants to stay safe,...
...help your neighbors and wash your hands.
Most of his tenants are young and many have recently lost their jobs.
It was really wonderful and I really needed it and it's helping me.
It's gonna make it a lot easier and a lot better and a lot less stressed out.
Mario is like one of the genuinely nicest people I've ever met.
Is it a help at a time like this?
For everybody.
For everybody, yeah.
I don't really look at it as being a hero.
I look at it as being human.
So, if I could make it easier on someone's life,...
...just pass it on.
Mario's selfless act as a landlord is sure to hit him financially,...
...but he says, if it helps his tenants, he really doesn't mind it.
It's a kind act and for many, needed now more than ever.